pour nous concentrer à nouveau.
Nous nous concentrons sur deux projets différents
avant de revenir à notre tâche initiale.
C'est la recherche de Gloria Mark, réunie à celle de Microsoft,
qui a montré ceci.
Et sa recherche a aussi montré que cela entraîne de mauvaises habitudes.
Plus nous subissons d'interruptions extérieures,
plus nous sommes conditionnés à nous interrompre.
Nous nous interrompons nous-mêmes tous les trois minutes et demie.
C'est fou.
Comment régler cela ?
Car Nancy et John sont dans cette relation de tout ou rien.
Nancy voudrait se déconnecter,
mais elle serait inquiète :
et si je loupais quelque chose d'important ?
Le design peut régler ce problème.
A nouveau, disons que Nancy est à gauche,
John à droite.
John se souvient qu'il doit envoyer ce document à Nancy.
Sauf que cette fois-ci,
Nancy peut noter qu'elle est concentrée.
Elle déplace un curseur et indique
vouloir être concentrée pendant 30 minutes
et elle est concentrée.
Quand John veut lui envoyer un message,
il peut se sortir cette idée de la tête --
car il a un besoin, il a cette idée
et il doit l'exprimer avant d'oublier.
Sauf que cette fois-ci,
les messages sont retenus pour que Nancy puisse être concentrée
et que John puisse se sortir cette idée de la tête.
Cela ne fonctionne que si un dernier point est vrai :
Nancy doit savoir que s'il y a quelque chose de vraiment important,
John peut l'interrompre.
Mais au lieu d'avoir ces interruptions constantes et irréfléchies,
nous ne créons que des interruptions conscientes.
Nous faisons alors deux choses.
Nous donnons le choix à Nancy et à John,
mais il a aussi une seconde chose, plus subtile :
nous changeons la question à laquelle nous répondons.
L'objectif du chat n'est plus
que ce soit facile d'envoyer un message --
c'est l'objectif du chat,
il devrait être simple d'envoyer un message à quelqu'un --
mais il a maintenant une valeur plus profonde et humaine :
créer la meilleure qualité de communication possible
dans une relation entre deux personnes.
Nous avons amélioré l'objectif.
Cela intéresse-t-il les designers ?
Voulons-nous avoir des conversations sur ces nouveaux objectifs ?
Je vais vous raconter une histoire.
Il y a un peu plus d'un an,
j'ai aidé à organiser une réunion
entre certains des meilleurs designers en technologie et Thich Nhat Hanh.
Thich Nhat Hanh est un porte-parole international
pour la méditation consciente.
La réunion était géniale.
Imaginez une pièce,
d'un côté nous avons des accros de haute technologies
et de l'autre côté nous avons
des moins bouddhistes en robe marron et avec la tête rasée.
Les questions posées relevaient des valeurs humaines profondes :
ce que sera le futur de la technologie
si elle est créée pour les questions
et les valeurs humaines profondes ?
Notre conversation était concentrée sur une écoute plus profonde
de ce que pourraient être ces valeurs.
Une blague a été faite :
et si le correcteur orthographique
devenait compassionnel ?
Il pourrait surligner les mots qui peuvent être accidentellement perçants,
perçus ainsi par quelqu'un d'autre.
Y a-t-il ce genre de conversations dans la vraie vie,
pas que dans ces réunions de design ?
La réponse est oui
et l'une de mes préférées est Couchsurfing.
Si vous l'ignorez, Couchsurfing est un site
qui met en relation des gens cherchant un endroit où dormir
avec un canapé libre et quelqu'un qui propose un canapé.
Super service --
Quel serait leur design ?
Que créez-vous si vous travaillez à Couchsurfing ?
Vous penseriez que l'objectif est de mettre en lien invités et hôtes,
n'est-ce pas ?
C'est un bon objectif.
Cela serait notre objectif pour la messagerie utilisée avant,
quand nous essayons juste d'envoyer un message.
Quel est l'objectif profond, humain ?
Leur objectif est défini ainsi :
le besoin de créer des relations et des expériences positives et durables
entre des personnes ne se connaissant pas.
Le plus génial à ce sujet est qu'en 2007,
ils ont introduit une façon de mesurer cela,
ce qui est incroyable.
Voici son fonctionnement.
Pour tout objectif de design,
il vous faut un moyen de mesure correspondant
pour évaluer votre réussite --
une évaluation du succès.
Voici ce qu'ils font :
ils prennent deux personnes qui se rencontrent,
ils comptent le nombre de jours qu'elles ont passés ensemble
et estiment combien d'heures cela représente --
combien d'heures ont-elles passées ensemble ?
Après le temps passé ensemble,
ils leur demandent
d'évaluer la positivité de leur expérience.
Votre rencontre était-elle une bonne expérience ?
Ils soustraient de ces heures positives
le temps passé sur le site
car c'est le coût dans la vie des gens.
Pourquoi serait-ce un succès ?
Il vous reste alors
une chose qu'ils appellent « la convivialité orchestrée net »
ou alors les « bons moments » nets créés.
Les heures nettes qui n'auraient pas existé sans Couchsurfing.
Pouvez-vous imaginer à quel point
ce serait inspirant de travailler chaque jour
et de mesurer votre succès
en contributions nettes d'heures dans la vie des gens
qui sont positives et n'auraient pas existé
si vous ne faisiez pas votre travail aujourd'hui ?
Pouvez-vous imaginer un monde entier fonctionnant ainsi ?
Pouvez-vous imaginer un réseau social qui --
disons que vous aimez cuisiner,
il mesurerait son succès en termes de soirées cuisine organisées
et les articles de cuisine que vous avez aimé lire,
y soustraierait les articles que vous n'avez pas aimé
ou le temps passé à naviguer ?
Imaginez un réseau social professionnel
qui, au lieu de mesurer son succès en termes de connexions créées
ou de messages envoyés,
mesurerait son succès en termes d'offres d'emploi reçues
et qui ont été appréciées.
Puis soustraierait le temps que les gens passent sur le site.
Imaginez des services de rencontre,
comme Tinder ou d'autres,
qui, au lieu de mesurer le nombre de likes ou de matchs,
qui est la mesure actuelle,
mesurait les connexions profondes, romantiques, épanouissantes créées.
Quoi que cela représente, d'ailleurs.
Mais pouvez-vous imaginer un monde entier fonctionnant ainsi,
qui vous aide à bien dépenser votre temps ?
Pour cela, vous avez besoin d'un nouveau système,
car vous pensez sûrement
que l'économie actuelle d'internet --
l'économie en général --
est mesurée en temps passé.
Plus vous avez d'utilisateurs,
plus vous êtes est utilisé,
plus les gens y passent de temps,
voilà notre mesure du succès.
Mais nous avons résolu ce problème auparavant.
Nous l'avons résolu avec de l'organique,
en disant que nous devions évaluer différemment les choses.
Nous avons dit que c'était un autre type de nourriture.
Le prix ne suffit pas pour comparer ;
c'est une autre catégorie de nourriture.
Nous l'avons résolu avec la certification LEED
en disant que c'était un autre type de bâtiment
ayant des valeurs environnementales différentes.
Si nous avions quelque chose de similaire pour la technologie ?
Si nous avions quelque chose dont l'objectif et le but
étaient d'aider à créer une contribution nette positive à la vie humaine ?
Si nous pouvions l'évaluer différemment,
pour que cela fonctionne ?
Imaginez avoir d'autres applications premium dans les stores,
des navigateurs internet vous aidant à trouver
ce genre de produits.
Imaginez-vous à quel point ce serait excitant de vivre et créer ce monde ?
Nous pouvons créer ce monde aujourd'hui.
Les dirigeants d'entreprise, tout ce que vous avez à faire --
vous pouvez prioriser une nouvelle métrique,
votre métrique pour la contribution nette positive à la vie humaine.
Discutez-en honnêtement.
Vous ne fonctionnez peut-être pas si bien,
mais ayons cette conversation.
Les designers, vous pouvez redéfinir le succès et le design.
Vous avez certainement plus de pouvoir que beaucoup dans votre organisation
pour créer les choix que nous suivons tous.
Comme en médecine,
où nous avons le serment d’Hippocrate
pour reconnaître la responsabilité et la haute valeur
du traitement des patients,
et si les designers avaient la même chose
pour ce nouveau genre de design ?
Et utilisateurs, nous tous --
nous pouvons exiger que la technologie fonctionne ainsi.
Cela peut sembler difficile,
mais McDonald's n'avait pas de salades avant que les consommateurs en demandent.
Walmart n'avait pas de produits bios avant que les consommateurs en demandent.
Nous devons exiger ce genre de technologie.
Nous pouvons le faire.
Et le faire
nous ferait passer d'un monde qui est piloté et dirigé
entièrement sur le temps passé,
à un monde piloté par le temps bien dépensé.
Je veux vivre dans ce monde
et je veux que nous ayons cette conversation.
Entamons cette conversation maintenant.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)